i do think you can eat pretty good
a little bit yeah yeah that's okay we
want you to rank the best super bowl
snacks so who came up with this list uh
that guy right there matt casey okay he
did a terrible terrible job
before we even start i'm gonna cross out
nachos okay i'm gonna cross out chili
and i'm gonna cross outside and i'm
gonna make some i'm gonna i'm gonna
substitute in the family of those things
okay so you look like a chili guy i know
well here's the thing though chris if
you have a super bowl party are you
really gonna feed like 20 people chili
yeah i don't want it in my bathroom i
don't want them in my bathroom right i
don't want them in my bathroom we're not
doing chili chili is a keep it to
yourself kind of thing you're right all
right so not instead of nachos we're
going to do various dips and then
parentheses buffalo chicken dip okay so
that's listen nachos you really can't
make nachos at home we're talking about
home yes the way you can maybe you know
at a restaurant right things get soggy
you got to make the meat there's too
much right a good buffalo chicken dip
yeah we'll beat nachos any day okay okay
yeah and then in okay uh we're taking
out sorry sliders i'll go to sliders
yeah we're gonna go pigs in a blanket
pegs in a blanket oh pigs in a blanket
definitely neater and easier just to
throw into your mouth and you can eat
about a million of them you can okay and
then uh instead of chili i cannot
believe it's not on here because you
need a healthy balanced
uh five course meal whatever it may be
right you gotta have dessert
dessert you're just going with dessert
are you gonna actually ever eat candy on
this day or is it just ice cream
cookies what i'm talking oh second half
is for dessert okay so now we got it set
okay i'm gonna go wings one yeah that's
a definite uh buffalo chicken dip two
okay pigs in blanket three pizza four
can you get it any time dessert five
dessert five all right i nailed it yeah
you did you sit right here second half
is for the brownies the cookies the ice
cream then you go back to the buffalo
chicken dip back to the pizza take note
everyone all the way around this guy is
a professional when it comes to this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports